[Music]
daddy is young bricks of three-window
smarter to tap out rebound
[Applause]
clovie way
[Music]
nice little behind
Oh back at home Sunday against Houston
oh my reddish showing off their laser
chef what a cappella me
take a look at this without the baseline
thereby reddish
[Music]
[Applause]
in meeting want and don't feel bad damn
it I've been in the same situation
[Music]
for one basket he made
but doing it a long time
[Music]
[Applause]
where to shoot
[Applause]
[Music]
we shot
[Music]
[Applause]
they love the basketball before the red
light comes on
yes he did Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to come up with a huge block while
career miele forgotten it could have got
the ball the time you guys to play very
well
[Applause]
little pick-and-roll action with Davis
have two five
these fakes
it was ki babies honor there is a totter
simatai they gave him a short
[Music]
[Applause]
under Taylor Jenkins what's up you guys
it's Taylor works with wheats report
make sure you subscribe for more video
content